what's your name Laura sunny Croft Lara  your father's gone you could pick up  where he left off I see so much of him  in you  pregnant  hello sprung if you're listening to this  then I must be dead I found something a  tune or the mother of death if Trinity  succeeds promise me  stop I think I know where my dad went  it's right in the middle of The Devil's  sea it will be an adventure an adventure  [Music]  you shouldn't have come here but I'm  glad that you did  my father now I see the likeness the  recklessness close the to once and for  the fate of humanity now in your hands  [Music]  don't be too careful these days  the world has gone bloody mad I'll take  two  [Music]